father's Arab Zay is in training for the
fights that could decide the direction
of his life
nine years after leaving Afghanistan at
age 15 he's made it into the world of
professional fighting thanks to the
mixed martial arts gym that saw his
talent when he was taken there by Social
Services
you see me now I'm a professional
fighter but when I arrived in France I
was a refugee and I slept on the street
I have the ultimate goal of becoming
world champion I train as hard as
possible but I need support because I'm
all alone I need support
[Music]
from being homeless to having his fights
broadcast worldwide is a huge
achievement
but for Arab sake the fight is as much
outside the cage as in it
mixed martial arts has given pave's a
new career since leaving Afghanistan but
simply turning professional is far from
enough to support a new life in France
Arab Zay has trained two months for a
fight this weekend that was canceled at
the last minute and that would have paid
him just two thousand dollars now he's
back to zero it's very difficult for him
to pay everything he has to pay here to
live in France so what we need is to get
sponsors sponsors will help a lot by
ways to prepare him well and to have a
good career in in MMA now
in one sense Arab Zay and his sparring
partner shecky bullet Waris another
Refugee but still an amateur are the
lucky ones
this is Syed Juarez hashimi a champion
MMA fighter in Afghanistan and a soldier
in the Afghan National Army he escaped
after the return of the Taliban and is
now stranded in Switzerland the founder
of the MMA Federation baz Muhammad
mubaras is living Visalus in Thailand
the Taliban band MMA in 2021
the Taliban should respect the pure will
of the Afghan people and athletes and
our athletes should train according to
the international law and participate in
competitions otherwise many of our young
MMA fighters will be left behind and
their hopes killed
in Paris parves arabzay leaves training
for an appointment with Social Services
hoping that his fighting spirit and
ability can overcome the administrative
and financial battles of a refugee's
life
Polaris altizera Paris